So, to look up algorithm, that a router
uses, depends on the protocol that it's using to
forward packets. And the look up mechanism might be
implemented with a variety of different algorithms or techniques.
For example, MPLS, ethernet, and ATM use an
exact match look up. Exact matches can be implemented
as a direct look up, and associative look up,
hashing, or via a binary tree. IPv4 and IPv6
on the other hand are implemented with what's called longest prefix
match. We've already looked at longest prefix match a little bit
in some lessons and, in this lesson we'll look at it
in a bit more detail as well as how it's implemented.
It might be implemented as a radix trie, a compressed trie.
Which is something that we will look at in this lesson.
And it can also be implemented as a binary search on
the prefix intervals. Ethenet based forwarding is based on exact match
of a layer two address. Which is usually 48
bits long. It's address is global, not just local to
the link. And the range or size of the
address is not negotiable. Now 2 to the 48th is
far bigger than 2 to the 12th, therefore, it's
not possible to hold all the addresses in the table
and use direct look up. The advantages of exact matches
and ethernet switches, is that exact match is simple and
the expected lookup time is small, or O of 1.
But the disadvantages include inefficient
use of memory. This potentially results
in nondeterministic lookup time if the lookup might require multiple memory
accesses. let's now take a closer look at longest prefix match.